c'est comment la vie dans le cas un mort
et un hélico my way love vie se fait
dans les caméras je peux dire c'est pas
facile je suis l'enfer jours l'enfer
c'est vraiment la faire qu'est-ce qu'il
est pire dans les vies et mourir le
pixel premiers mois je veux dire c'est
la sécurité
on vit dans l'insécurité on a passé de
réviser sa sécurité le petit déjeuner
après l'électricité les toilettes eu
vraiment dire tout ça passe très
difficile cela je dis bien que cela
ferait qu est ce que vous aimeriez que
le gouvernement afin que l'europe fasse
normalement on est dans l'espace
européen
on est dans un pays qui alliée de
l'espace schengen ce que vous devez
vraiment avoir du papier et si on a de
papier ça va ça va nous aider à faire la
libre circulation je dois accepter
bloqués ici avec la difficulté qui se
passe ici ça le maire de la tête c'est
que les gens vis ici de voir le papier
d'être légalisé ça va le 2 des deux
parties afin de rester toujours en moi
parce que c'est comme si en prison tu
dois rester seulement ici il n'a pas de
bons nourrit-il à la difficulté phare à
la toilette la sécurité des gens qui
kiffent on adore les gens chaque jour
donc il ya deux blessés chaque jour
c'est parfois facile c'est que les gens
veulent du pont du papier et des partis
là où il veut
le gouvernement grec doit donner de
papier par les gens qui ont pensé déjà
leurs interviews il doit s'ouvrir le
procès d'hier ailleurs vous êtes un mot
rien depuis longtemps ce que vous avez
sport de partir bientôt
non moi je quatre ans ici je comptera
pas ici à mourir en grèce je vais à
l'antenne c'était pas légal ou m'arrêter
je me suis retourné six ans suivant le
procédé des paquets je me suis retourné
si ça fait toujours moins quatre mois je
suis
j'étais en prison je fais 11 mai en
prison m'a libéré je suis ici pour
suivre et du ça fait déjà quatre
messieurs pas facile je connais bien
grèce parce que j'ai pas partout en
grèce n'avait pas de papiers mais je
connais presque et de provence des
graisses si je connais bien la grèce et
s'entretenir
quand on leur décision ne change pas
pour l'instant je vois venir y la
difficulté pour le papier ne donne pas
des papiers les gens qui opportunité de
prendre les papiers c'est ce que sont
venus en 2020 ce sont leurs qu'il
examine leurs problèmes les autres est
un entre-deux des patientes et toujours
est ce que vous sentez que les
immigrants sont les bienvenus en europe
c'était au moins bien à l'époque d alex
hitz passe parce que c'est un démocrate
menacée mais tout acquis les
républicains donc tu vois là c'est un
peu d'échangés des choses c'est pas
vraiment facile mais on sait qui on est
en europe
on va tenter d'aller comme d'habitude
les gens s'ils font du papier de tombes
d'aller en france belgique comme
d'habitude parce que grèce il a une
crise économique relève vraiment les
ficelles difficulté de gérer tout dit à
mes gars là c'est normal
comme on est dans l'espace chanel et
j'attends toujours aller france belgique
pour 20 nouvelles vu ce que les gens qui
les africains qui est de l'afrique parce
qu'il ya la misère qu'elle vient en
europe pour prendre une nouvelle vie
qu'ils attendaient comme il voit ici le
trouve les réalités les autres plaire
qu'à man je croyais qu ici ou vendent
inspire ise je vais changer la vie mais
comment toujours le même chose qu'à
l'afrique
donc ce sont vraiment les produits vous
ne vous sentez pas les bienvenus ici
j'imagine non vraiment pas vraiment pas
vraiment parce que il ya même des
organisations qui soutiennent les
migrants il passé s'ils comptent sur le
bienvenu on va te respecte et qu'on ne
souhaitait km et quand tu manges pas
bien de chalain sécurité ne pas les
bienvenus il n'y a pas d'électricité les
gardes pouvait faire tout pour nous
donner d'abord l'électricité parce qu'on
en parle de l'hiver
comme nous sommes comme des doors fellay
la personne qui viennent au secours on
pleure tous les jours rien ne change on
ne paie pas l'argent on paye 90 euros 90
euros ça va pas nous aider à faire
toutes nos régions il n'y a pas de bonne
ou russie qui préparation quand on nous
avait promis de prendre quarante cinq
héros ajouta par rapport à toutes les
mois de l'hiver on après seulement un
mois 45 euros je finis par mena on y
retourne dans la merde ça pose un
problème c'est l'insécurité
ici encore y'a vraiment l'insécurité
prenant deuxièmement les toilettes n'est
pas bon
regardez comme les gens dorment et aussi
donc c'est pas facile
c'est pour cela je t'avais du haut débit
ici c'est l'enfer parce que je quatre
ans ici je sais comment ça marche
c'est pas facile pour les africains et
les arabes sont habitués des prix leur
pays de leurs conditions de leur
nourriture mais les africains
le but n'est pas de se retirer si de se
trouver ici donc cela tu as les
africains ils ont entre des souffrir par
rapport à terre d'autres continents